hello i'm alvin welcome back to tasty's
making it big the show where i make
giant food for my friends guests and
often times myself and today we're gonna
make a giant quesadilla because i think
i just really want a quesadilla so i'm
gonna make a big one
well can't have a giant quesadilla
without giant tortilla we're gonna add
in shortening to flour i know that
traditionally
lard may be used but we tried it and it
doesn't really work out when tortilla
needs to be very big this was our
solution oh this is soft now i'm going
to add in the salt i'm just like the
kids playing in the sand and this is hot
water and slowly bit by bit oh it's
getting nice as you can see i seem to be
spilling everywhere you could probably
make a compilation of all the spills
that i've done on the show and it'd be
the same length as a normal episode this
is my workout for the day one set
500 tortilla dough rips okay it's like
kind of coming together
ow shouldn't have done that why usually
when i do that it doesn't hurt put this
in here you guys are going to take a nap
good night
okay i'm going to cook the chicken now
because i like chicken quesadillas so we
have a small batch of chicken thighs
this is 1 6 of all the chicken we're
going to use i love thighs because it's
like so flavorful and they're like soft
and juicy salt paprika white pepper
garlic powder and some cumin some oil
absorb all this good seasoning in all
the little cracks and crevices which is
also why chicken thighs taste so good
because they're not flat as you can see
this chicken is now completely different
color so that means it's ready to be
cooked
[Music]
that sounds nice oh it smells good
already don't want the spices to burn so
i'm just gonna check on them oh yeah
that's a good color already yeah chicken
is like when it's orange red yellow dark
brown that's a sign the chicken is good
it smells crazy good nice char some good
seasoning the juices are coming out i'm
gonna take them out you can hang out
over here with your little buddies now
that we have approximately 30 to 40
chicken thighs ready we can cook the
vegetables because in this pan there's
some delicious fun spices and flavor
that should not go to waste so i will
set this
to the side and we'll get the vegetables
okay so the chicken is done but
quesadilla isn't complete without some
nice vegetables so there's red onion
green bell pepper red bell pepper
cooking in the cast iron because a lot
of flavor in here and we're just gonna
heat it back up again okay onions
smells good red onions my arch enemy now
you shall pay for all the tears you have
given me okay a little bit of color i
don't want to cook them too much and now
these can go in here okay green bell
pepper in you go
and we're spilling again okay don't do
that out
so the red bell peppers are looking
pretty good yeah i don't want to get
them too dark because and they won't be
red anymore so these are done minimal
spillage may or may not have cleaned up
when the cameras were turned away now
that these are done let these cool off a
little bit let the moisture evaporate
and i'm gonna go shred a lot of cheese
[Music]
well most of the reason why i'm excited
to make a giant quesadilla is because i
get to play with cheese this is like a
quarter of the cheese that we're
actually gonna do this is mozzarella i
love mozzarella it's great very soft
very creamy so this is about one pound
it's probably gonna be about 10 pounds
of cheese in the final quesadilla so i
have a lot of shredding to do remember
how i said earlier that tortilla was my
workout of the day well i guess this is
my second workout
all right allen stop being a wuss just
cheese man almost there come on alvin
i'm just gonna rip this one
that's okay you can have chunks
oh that's one pound all right i'm gonna
take a break let's just let's do some
cheddar
it's a lot of work
oh my god i'm gonna be here for a long
time
we'll be right back after these messages
we don't have messages we're just gonna
be right back
i'm very tired
we're almost there oh once i lift up
this thing it'll all be worth it i hope
we're living life close to the edge
literally just gonna chop this up a
little bit thank you bench scraper all
right let's see what
mountain of cheese looks like
that's pretty cool like a christmas tree
let's get you into this bowl okay so i
got really tired about halfway through
and asked our wonderful culinary team in
the back to help me with this but we
have oh this is heavy five pounds i
think actually seven pounds of
mozzarella freshly shredded five pounds
of cheddar freshly shredded
okay so good cheeses are done i think
it's time to cook this tortilla i don't
need all this
[Music]
so we are in the tasty kitchen where i'm
going to roll out this dough baby it's a
flour
i'm gonna roll it out oh that's nice
this is a soft dough
so satisfying
third workout
who needs a personal trainer when you
can just make big food and eat it after
you're done exercising okay so the pot
i'm cooking it in is 20 inches long so i
have to see if we're good
oh yeah we're at a right at a healthy 25
so i think i think we're okay it's gonna
shrink a little bit so that's okay this
is the pan
that we're gonna cook it in all right
i'm gonna get this guy in there see if i
can do this without messing it up let's
get it in the pan i'm gonna move it
around before it starts to set nice
oh that hurt that's okay this is a good
looking tortilla the pan is very hot
so it'll get a nice sear i'm gonna trim
some of the edges you can hear the
sizzle which is a very good sign i'll
eat those scraps later okay this will
cover and it'll cook
for a little bit after a while we're
gonna flip it
i don't know how but
we always figure it out so
bye-bye
i think this is ready
it's all steamy and
i'm gonna try to flip it this is not
gonna be safe so please don't do this at
home
all right here we go
[Music]
slowly ah yes
flipped don't do that at home
look at that all right this goes back on
here
and we're gonna get this back into the
pan look at these look at this color wow
it's like a freshly cooked tortilla it's
great okay back in the pan you go dude
ah yes there we go
that's what i'm talking about
okay so we have all the stuff i like to
make my quesadillas and kind of mix it
all together so all the flavors can
commingle so i want to start chopping up
this beautiful chicken
this is that good stuff oh so juicy
that's for me like a dream come true
this is so good holy moly i can't stop
eating it it's so good
all right
get this in here beautiful
it's a cascade of yummy meat okay let's
keep going
i hope i don't get full by the time of
this picture of these
little snacks
i think we have enough chicken okay next
we have vegetables going in yum yum and
finally
the cheese
all of this goes in oh yeah look at that
oh yeah you going too this is the kind
of mixture where the people go would you
like some chicken with your cheese sir
the answer is yes it's a good thing i'm
very hungry today i'm going to eat a lot
of this i know it won't be good for me
but it'll be good for my mind let's give
this a little taste because i'm hungry
[Music]
i think we're ready to make this
quesadilla
oh this is heavy
i think it's time to assemble the
question is is all of this going to fit
on this
my answer is that yes so we're going to
get as much of this on there as we can
and compact it smells so
good is one loaded quesadilla just press
it down give it a good shape oh my god
okay this is actually a little thick
this is the ratio of
filling to tortilla that i like in my
quesadillas oh my god this is a thick
pizza i mean quesadilla well and if that
wasn't enough cheese
we have some provolone because in
quesadillas are just an excuse to eat
more cheese so we're going to go in a
beautiful circle this really is like a
pizza huh
that looks awesome now for the second
tortilla beautiful
look at you i like this very much squish
it into place
and now we wrap it up get the sides
first see if we can make this work i'll
just slide it on oh my god this is so
heavy
all right that one
move it on
it's wrapping all nice
time to get him back on the tray if i
can
all right don't drop this like you
dropped the oreo you dummy
tada
and i dropped the dough
perfect
all right yes
all right so the quesadilla is now
wrapped up this is going to go into an
oven for quite a long time goodbye
[Music]
okay this has been baking
for a whole hour
i'm very excited it smells great
look at that
dang
this smells crazy so we got it on the
table this is the quesadilla it's like
25 pounds and we have pico de gallo
guacamole and sour cream and two little
limes all right alvin don't mess this up
let's go here
oh there's a nice sound
very juicy so big we need two spatulas
and a knife i feel like the knife is not
safe but we shall see
well this looks delicious i'm gonna find
a plate
so i have a little slice of the
quesadilla right here for me i like
toppings so i'm gonna serve myself sour
cream
some guacamole and some pico
that's built you know just for safety a
little bit of luck apparently this is
the only fork and knife we have left all
the rest on the dishwasher so here we go
some of that
cheers
[Music]
hmm
oh look whoa
this might be the best thing we've made
on this show so far damn am i surprised
no not really i knew what i was putting
in this quesadilla how could it not be
good come on
i'm beyond happy with this wow it's a
good thing i like this so much i've made
this for me and because i made it for me
i'm going to eat this so if you excuse
me i have a lot of calories to consume
peace
[Music]
you